il s'agit d'utiliser la matière comme le
tissu comme matière les tissus comme
couleur pour rendre un effet radka banc
qui revient à la petite enfance ou ma
grand-mère partait au marché de foncer
niveau l'habitait à saint pierre avec un
chariot sur la tête a tiqué sur la tête
et elle remontait pour le déjeuner pour
parer les jeunes et pour les
petits-enfants avec des friandises avec
des défis niveau et après la laisse
reposer et se couchait sur la rade
cabane donc l'image est tout de suite
venu vers moi ma grand-mère ceyrat
cabanes ou plus du témoignage de réalité
qui n'existe pratiquement plus parce que
maintenant plus personne ne me dira de
carbone dans son sous son matelas
mais bon les gens qui continue parce
qu'il m'a s'applique à laval mais moi je
voulais sublimer la la couleur et la
matière en disant on ne peut très bien
travailler
peindre sans avoir besoin de couleurs
même si là par exemple
là par exemple n'y a pas de couleurs
absolument aucune couleur exécutif du
tissu qui viennent en filigrane et qui
donne une dimension une épaisseur la
fête la peinture ajoute il manque un
véhicule
j'habitais rue turgot j'avais à côté de
chez ma mère une dame qui peinait un peu
qui faisait de la peinture et de la
sculpture et que fasciner ensuite je
suis venu vraiment la peinture plus tard
grâce à grâce à l'intermédiaire enfin un
coup de pied au derrière il ya 2000 à
ouchy c'est lui qui m'a poussé à me
lancer en disant il récuse tout indique
qu'il a à nous dire
et puis après bon j'ai voyagé et puis
c'est une façon pour moi de me retrouver
à dans ma solitude est dans la réflexion
que j'ai besoin pour travailler la
diplomatie roumaine
par la peinture diplomatie amène à tous
c'est à dire que quand on est quand on
est quand on est dans un pays étranger
qu'on se retrouve confronté à ces deux
problèmes difficulté et quand ce sera le
froid se fait ravir souffle à dîner et
puis ensuite il faut commencer à
réfléchir à autre chose pour se vider la
tête et la couleur permet de se vider la
tête des outils c'était ça c'est un
pinceau un couteau avant sa mort ce
morceau de mousse commencé de des pages
et puis faire travailler partait à
travailler seul et mieux travailler
lorsque je voulais montrer aujourd'hui
ma manière je n'ai pas la prétention de
pouvoir la vérité mais effectivement la
misère affective et un soubassement des
ans tous les tous les travaux que j'ai
fait dans tous les pays j'ai voyagé j'ai
tout réglé avec la mise et avec ceux qui
quittent l essentiel n de la population
et des gens or en martinique les rattes
carbone c c'est en gt rien à l'époque
mais tellement sous le matelas qu'on
récupère et peut-être le carnaval mais
il y avait un aller retour dire que les
femmes c'est saint servais pour faire
distance champ pour faire ce genre de
choses et si vous voulez récupérer cela
c'est à dire on est en combat en combat
permanent qu'il faut faut qu'on se batte
pouvoir résister et puis voilà on peut
pas assez pléré annou lité quoi c'est à
dire qu'il faut il faut qu'il montre que
le bo à travers toutes les composantes
du beau et compris le lay la misère